so rich
what are you looking forward to in 2023
no
um building a little bunker taking a
deep hole I'm just going to hide as deep
and as far as I can but when I'm not
doing that I'll still be looking at the
UFO subject I'll still be looking at the
dissolution of global geopolitics and
the world around us and seeing how long
we can hang on before
things get really crazy if you think
they're crazy now I think it's going to
be a lot more a lot more ahead in 2023 I
don't think there's going to be a
respite from the insanity
and I wanted to tell the audience where
they could find more out about you or
what you have going on next and I was
supposed to take that link I don't know
if I did uh it's just fine don't worry
about it I have a I I had a new book
that I uh I just did a new edition of
one of my books
but I have it here can I show it on this
so yeah my latest UFOs for the 21st
century mind uh the old Edition had a
bit of a Monty Python look this is
actually a little you close for the 21st
century this is Richard Dolan's work I'm
pinning it so people who would like to
search this and buy it or at least check
it out here is the title and again it'll
be in the description once this finally
goes thank you thank you it's I wrote
quite a bit more to this so it's an
updated version of a book that I wrote
almost a decade ago and I just wanted to
bring the UFO story up today to the end
of 2022 which I just did so I was happy
about that
um but I keep myself busy with all kinds
of analysis of the UFO situation is
there going to be a disclosure in the
next year or two or not we're going to
progress we're going to regress and I
have conversations with people pretty
much every day
uh about that matter it just never stops
I think we're in a really uh you know
I think when we were all of us were
little I don't think any of us had an
idea of just how fast-paced the world
was going to become
uh it's always been fast but my goodness
it's just gone into high gear so
uh I'm definitely going to be looking
forward to monitoring and commenting on
everything that happens in my little
area for the coming year that's for sure
and your YouTube channel is Richard
Dolan you just searched that correct
uh Richard Allen intelligent disclosure
yeah uh name of one of my programs and I
do have a website I have a members
website Richard olamembers.com where I
do a lot of work there as well uh for a
really cool community of people
so uh that is that is what I do yeah
okay you're staying on you're not
getting up that easy but not that easily
I want to let in Dr Brian Keating
as well as one of the runner-ups for the
contest his name is Brad from Sonic
gravity
hello Dr Brian Keating the legend the
legend is here and Brad I've heard so
much about you so you're a legend as
well at least to myself we're gonna
stick with Brian keating's intro first
so Brian
Brian is a I don't I don't know how you
do it man like
not only if you just read Wikipedia as
to your accolades and your current
status so you're not only a professor
you're a particular kind of Professor
the chancellor chair of someone so like
you're gonna say it much better than I
can I don't recall it just like
six adjectives before your name usually
and then you have a podcast and then not
only that but you put up way more
content than myself which I'm
desire yourself and and
yeah extremely desire yourself
you also have kids you don't just have
one kid which is more than enough you
have five kids
and then I think there's something else
you're doing which I I think you're also
working up or at least you used to work
on the Galileo project and there's
probably other projects and you have PhD
students and geez man holy moly like I
work like a dog right and I work like a
dog and probably get like 10 is 50 is at
most as much as you so welcome Dr Brian
King I need you so the podcast is Dr
Brian Keaton podcast into the impossible
thank you guys thank you Kurt it's a
pleasure honor to be here you're one of
my early Inspirations and my continuing
um I would say you're you're sort of a
mentor to Meeker you've done a lot
you've inspired so many millions of
people around the world and uh you know
I'm just trying to grow a quality
audience like you've done and doing so
in the in the kind of nooks and crannies
as you mentioned you know I have a lot
of obligations and responsibilities at
the University and the thing I'm most
looking forward to outside of my family
and my home life and my friends is to
grow and develop the
uh the Simon's Observatory which is the
world's highest operating astronomical
Observatory it's actually the highest uh
construction project in the world it's
at 5200 meters above sea level in the
Atacama Desert and I was just there a
couple of weeks ago
spent uh about a week there and it's
it's just Paradise for nerds when you're
up there and there's nothing you can do
there's no Wi-fi all you could do is
work and you've got this massive
telescope array of three enormous
telescopes and it's going to be joined
by a six meter diameter reflecting
telescope my three refracting telescopes
this is you know kind of what I dreamed
of as a kid uh I just didn't have the
110 million dollars that it takes so
thank you Kurt thank you Kurt's patreon
but she funnels to me no no he doesn't
do that I do support Kurt so I I want to
ask you all out there if you can give
Kurt a little bit of of feedback and the
way that humans have done this since the
Phoenicians invented the the concept of
fungibility and coinage and and money is
to become a patron of kirchi mungle uh
who who has promised by and I have it as
proof he's going to visit me in Southern
California where I am not right now I'm
in an undisclosed
Subterranean bunker where I'm hoping to
go skiing with some of my kids uh but
um but please support Kurt so I need he
needs a uh he needs to make a proper
introduction come and do a live podcast
in my new studio at UC San Diego where I
am the Chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics and we're going to
do a video together and I've already
started
so it's going to be epic in the studio
in the laboratory
okay all right I will go for eight hours
so I'll record one with you you record
one with me and by the way don't just
support me support Brian support Rich
support Brad who is about to be
introduced Brad please sir introduce
yourself you know mine and I want to
just thank you for submitting not only
submitting but but I want to thank you
for producing a quality video
hey thanks I you say quality I know you
you're defining that too I'm very
Loosely because uh I mean I my tech is
really low can you guys hear me it might
sound okay yeah but uh no I just want to
say Kurt uh well I'm a I'm a vet uh I'm
a engineer and a lawyer
um and when the Navy said that UFOs are
real
just my brain started spinning and I
just got really focused on how to how
could it possibly happen
and uh so I just started like you do any
other engineering project I said well
they look massless what causes Mass it's
the Higgs field at least that's what
um space-time uh Dr Matt O'Dowd said and
then I was like well how do I get a hold
of higgsfield and he said had an episode
that said the left-handed electron uh
is getting snagged by the Higgs field
so then I said well what how do I grab
left lane electrons so I created a
faraday disc
create a magnetic field and I found some
research from Dr Lawrence Eaves at
University of Nottingham that said if
you pass it through a hexagonal
molecular structure like graphene or
bismuth or nickel um it teases out left
and right hand electrons
and so then I you see that oscilloscope
behind me that platform that that scale
so I built that Faraday disk
put that plate on top of it turned it on
and I got about two pounds lighter
so now I'm trying to
um essentially you know if you shake the
left hand electron the left arm is
holding onto the Fig field of course I
have a non non-consensus theory that the
Higgs field is negative energy density
gravity and so just a moment Brad
because if people aren't following this
I want to leave a link to your work so a
link will be imminent and then I'm going
to pin it that's just for people who are
wondering what the heck is happening so
please continue
yeah so if you can shake 246 gig
electron volts into that left-handed
electron that you caught in your in your
Faraday disk magnetic field so you can
see behind me there's the oscilloscope
it's dual Channel it has one polarizing
field and then it has a harmonic one
that bounces the field I run through a
car stereo to jack up the wattage
but um but essentially it shakes the uh
hopefully I mean I'm hoping that what
I've hit is a resonant frequency that
reduces the Hicks to the ground state
and lowers the mass of whatever's inside
of it and then it just kind of after
that sort of hey that's what quantum
gravity is and then it just kind of led
me down this complete rabbit hole and I
started learning quantum physics and
just kind of seeing how everything fits
and I think and I don't Dr Keating is a
privilege Kurt it's a privilege to be on
your Dr Nolan I mean you guys are all
great I mean I'm crying right now inside
and I screenshotted it so I can like
show my family that I was next to famous
people but I think space time blows out
of black holes which is why the universe
expands and the further you look out I'm
so pumped to just even be in your guys
Aura thank you so much
um but yeah I just I do it in my free
time uh I have a regular day job and
everything and I only have four kids
though so well Brad Pitt is engaged
is Dr Keith
I I
saw firstly
so thank you for your comments about
that that's that's incredibly kind and
I'm Richard and Brian I'm sure we're all
like super flattered by that so so thank
you and and I do have to let you go now
only out of fairness to everyone else
who is at The Honorable who's honorably
mentioned I only gave him about a couple
minutes so I'm Gonna Let You Go and
it'll join Brian and Richie but thank
you and we'll speak again okay
sure it was a pleasure for people who
are interested again I will leave the
link right
[Music]
it'll be in the description I'll leave
the link in the description I placed it
on the on screen several times already
okay thanks Brad
thank you yeah man talk to you soon
Okay so
all right Rich Brian
oh we're still here yes
so I want to know
Brian I don't think I asked you what do
you have
what are you most excited about about
I think this year is going to be a year
of transition where we take discoveries
and we subject them uh to really intense
scrutiny I think we're coming out of a
dark period for science where science
was subjugated at the will of political
and media
imperatives and I think you know thanks
to Elon musk's generosity and and buying
Twitter I think a lot of that has been
liberated and because of that I think
there will be a new sort of Renaissance
and I like in the last three years to
sort of a Dark Age like you you almost
couldn't have a flourishing of say
engineering you know during the during
the Dark Ages so so-called Dark Ages it
turns out they weren't that dark but
let's get into that some other time
um we couldn't have like flourishing art
and architecture and then like
suppression of of thought and uh and and
Science and all sorts of things in other
words concomitant with the overbearing
social uh pressures that came from
political uh factions uh with those
being alleviated
uh that has really uh stemmed a tide
that made me very nervous very worried
and I say that I've had two
conversations in the last month of my
podcast one with actually three one one
with professor Charles seif just last
week about nuclear fusion and they
claimed you know Revelation and
breakthrough which kind of showed the
governmental um you know hype cycle I
call it the academic media
complex industrial complex I'm gonna
have a video about that soon
um along with things like the quantum
Computing Wormhole which I have an
upcoming video about as well these are
hype things and then you have
of legitimate scientific discoveries or
practice of science like the James Webb
Space Telescope that was embroiled in a
controversy recently over the name being
named after James Webb and he was
accused falsely of being a homophobe and
this actually caused a great deal of of
uh of pressure on a good friend of mine
past guest hakima lashayi who's a very
well-known physicist himself who happens
to be black and he set on a campaign to
investigate did James Webb practice
homophobia found negative did not and
yet his life hakeem's was turned upside
down because of non-scientific reasons
people that just hated this notion that
gays and lesbians should be persecuted
which we all should abore but at the
same token uh this this came about
and then the last thing was Dr J
bhattacharya uh one of the co-authors of
the Great Barrington declaration who
promoted Common Sense covid navigation
and he was called by the most powerful
two people in all of science right now
to the extent that you can identify
scientific bureaucrats as being powerful
uh Francis Collins director of the NIH
and Tony fauci who needs no introduction
um he's not coming on is he is he Kurt
is he coming on a live stream I hope not
yeah so uh to hear the treatment of Jay
and how much has changed just in the
last few months is really a breath of
fresh air so I'm looking forward to
discovers I had an epic tweet thread I
posted yesterday predictions for 2023 in
science also the UFO project I'm uh very
good friends with the NASA UAP study
director doesn't give me any special uh
favors Dr David spurgle who's been a
two-time guest on my podcast uh he's
leading the NASA study and he's going to
do a phenomenal job when that comes out
he's promised to come on my podcast and
reveal you know some of the inner
workings of how they came to their
public findings Dr Shelley Wright is a
colleague at UC San Diego she studies
Optical study incredibly interesting
using looking for laser light Pulses
from distant civilizations so I'm
looking forward to all that she's also
going to be a guest on the podcast so
stay tuned for that I like to do and as
you know you're You're The Theory of
Everything I almost changed my channel
from into the impossible to experiment
sense of everything because you cover
all the theories of everything someone's
got to do the Hands-On instrument
building Hardware technical things I
said we're Hodge dual to one another
that's right
yeah we are we are I don't know who's
who's the complex though
so so Richie sorry if I keep calling you
Richard I just mean that in an endearing
manner Richard what
what are some things that ordinary
people can do outside of petitioning
their government
to facilitate UFO disclosure or to help
get some
get less befuddling of the UFO scene and
more illumination
uh I'll answer that but I just want to
say this is the first time I've heard
Brian Keating speak and uh I kind of
like the
political analysis I agree with musk and
Twitter
um and pretty much I think everything
else you said Brian I'm looking forward
to seeing how that NASA UFO UAP study
goes I have a little bit less confidence
maybe than you do that will be according
to what I think it really ought to be
but that's just based on NASA's long
long history of UFO obfuscation and
actual dishonesty that they've had and a
lack of um
really good work done on it but maybe
this will be different and I'm looking
at that uh
uh carefully and critically as well as
far as your question Kurt
um
well I think the conversation we're
having on UAP or UFOs in our society
it's much much better than it's been
five years ago uh and long before that
where it was utterly impossible to have
a an adult mature conversation about
this subject in the public domain it was
just it got shut down every time so it's
a little bit better now we're still at
the tiniest of baby steps in terms of
really grasping what this phenomenon is
about uh we're still at the point where
we have scientists saying gee I wonder
if there's something out there is this
anomalous and so forth
um I've been looking at I've looked at
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of cases many Declassified military
case is not simply from the U.S but from
other nations as well and there's no
question that this is not simply
something that's real but it's a
significant high level national security
issue that at times has taken on
uh Monumental and Ultra grave
proportions uh more than once so it's
obviously something very serious it is
enmeshed with the intelligence and
military communities primarily of the
United States but also elsewhere there's
a lot of obfuscation you know I did a
lot of time looking at the Davis Wilson
notes I was one of the few people
initially who really stood by them in
2019 and 2020 when a lot of people were
still trashing them I knew that they
were legit I know they are legit and the
implications of what are in those
documents is those notes are quite
significant describes a
deeply deeply clandestine classified
special Access program series of
programs
that are
maybe with the legal fiction of having
some government purview but in a sense
in essence they really don't have much
government oversight and anything
meaningful at all
and
um appear strongly appear I would say to
have
to do with the possession of non-human
technology and even bodies I think all
of that is real the other thing that we
need to be talking about is the ongoing
massive daily presence of these unknown
craft over people's neighborhoods every
single day
uh you can look around there are a
couple of repositories that accept good
UFO cases
they don't all get great investigations
it is true but when you go through the
data I think it becomes undeniable to a
reasonable mind that every single day at
two in the morning three in the morning
there's a craft that might be hovering
over your neighborhood at 200 feet
people see these things all the time and
I would like to know who the heck is
behind them what are they doing what's
the mission
are these aliens or not I don't think
they're black budget so there's there's
a lot of uh progress that we need to be
making on the UFO matter what can people
do
well this is a subject with a steep
learning curve I've learned that 25
years ago I thought I'll take uh two
three months out of my life and get up
to speed on it right and that was a long
long time ago so it takes a long while
to become what I would say is genuinely
sophisticated in one's understanding of
a subject it's been laughed at for years
and decades and I think uh and I and I
don't know
um you Brian so I would never make an
assumption but I do find that many many
highly intelligent people with great
education underestimate this subject and
they think that they've got it when in
fact they're at the bottom of the
mountain so there's a long way to go
yeah I agree Richard I think there's a
lot of um there's a lot of hubris right
there's the kind of Camp the Elon Musk
camp that we've had great cameras for
decades and they've been improving in
the quality of UFO sightings has got you
know it's easy to dismiss and elon's a
brilliant man I hope to have them on my
podcast at some point uh then there's
actually an abundance of excellent video
photographic evidence that is out there
that just gets ignored
right quite a bit so what I what I like
to do is think about it as an astronomer
that's what I'm trained as I do build
instrumentation I like to think of the
physics implications and you know for a
long time I simply applied Pascal's
wager to this whole problem if it is
real the penalty for you know not
believing it is infinite almost right we
could lose out on four centuries of
physics progress another hand if it
isn't real quote whatever that means I'm
not going to get debated right now but
it isn't real and you spend some time on
it first of all you're learning a
tremendous amount right let's not forget
all the things we've learned about
um just from the consideration of the
existence of extraterrestrial life we've
learned about Material Science we've
learned about Imaging and we've learned
propulsion systems and and then I'm also
a pilot I fly little planes around here
in California and um one of the things
that's interest you know to me and I
know I'm interested in NASA outside of
the alien issue is how could these
objects be threats how could they
interfere with the safety of of the
public and I think that's actually been
downplayed I mean Kurt and I hosted
along and people are still talking about
that that's probably my most popular
video in the last couple years and that
video you know people are making fun of
it now on the other hand I also I don't
shy away from upgrading you know the
Believers the so-called you know I want
to believe type folks I say look I asked
Tom this point blank I said you claim
you have evidence let's talk about the
evidence where is it how'd you get it
how did you come to it can we test it
can we subject it in my laboratory well
we could do some of those things but you
know we lost track of it we don't have
provenance at a certain point Richard
you know you scientifically minded per
people and like you and me we would say
look at a certain point that evidence
doesn't fully rise to to you know the
point of scientific
um this positive in other words many
evidence as eyewitness evidences I mean
I don't use eyewitness evidence and
cosmology because there were no
eyewitnesses to the Big Ben but uh I
think we have to be we have to be um
open and not have that hubris that
you're speaking about the other hand we
can't also say that because I want to
believe something that I'm almost going
to be as accepting of of technology and
claims and and visitations and sightings
and so forth
um and and kind of not use our
scientific training I I don't know if
you'd agree with that but that's right I
use my historical training so I'm not a
scientifically trained man I'm a
historian and so what I've been
interested in doing is trying to figure
out a historical puzzle which is why
have leading uh directors of the Central
Intelligence Agency four-star generals
three star generals of the US and
elsewhere taking this problem so
seriously and why has there been so much
obfuscation and secrecy around it that's
undeniable fact and and then furthermore
what is what could be the meaning behind
the many hundreds I would say thousands
of Declassified military reports that
describe rather dramatic encounters with
UFOs so that's the situation that I'm
interested in rather than explaining it
scientifically it's trying to understand
it historically and understand why it
was taken seriously by some of the most
brilliant responsible National Security
people and in our lifetime
what do you think Richard
yeah I'm sorry oh no I'm just gonna ask
Richard and YouTube
yeah I just want to ask Richard and you
Kurt
um one of the things I've been thinking
about is sort of the analog of a Turing
test but for classifying you know
sightings encounters or whatever and um
and that's very this is something people
can really latch on to and they can
participate on in fact before I joined
the show I had to prove that I was a
human being you know via a recaptcha
type system right
um and so Richard and Kurt I wonder you
know could we sort of crowdsource you
know these things and kind of the the
citizen science Brigade and call for
that in addition to professional
scientists like myself actually working
on Avi lobe Gary Nolan you know Etc
working on this phenomena but like have
a recapture you know how can we classify
things just at the data level is that
even possible as a way to engage citizen
scientists
there are ways to do this absolutely
there are projects going on right now
and I wish I could remember the German
professor's name who's doing this I was
just chatting about him the other day
who has um a proof of concept that he's
working on essentially having cameras to
uh with with uh AI of algorithms to
identify uh conventional objects but but
to have the cameras dedicated in a
portion of the sky so that it would
capture
um increasingly would capture unknown
objects I think uh you know there's all
kinds of projects like that which makes
sense and which are feasible and uh that
could have results
um you know I think there's a lot of
smart people out there with all kinds of
uh ideas you could try to capture
objects and other elements of the
Electric magnetic Spectrum
um whether it's IR or anything else and
that's one thing and you know the real
the real meat and potatoes comes down to
whether or not we can actually
unlock the secrecy and I'm a firm
believer that there's been a
long-standing cover-up conspiracy you
want to call it
um in which ET Tech has been acquired I
and I I'll just add I don't know how
much more time I have here but
I think that our species
uh you know we've existed as Homo
sapiens for about 300 000 years last
estimate from um paleontologists
and only in the last generation or so
have we been
maybe let's be generous and say the last
century have we really had a truly
modern society
you know up until then we were just
horses pulling wooden carts and not even
that so we're in a place right now that
if there's anyone out there who has the
ability to watch us I would be quite
sure that they will they are sure as
heck going to want to watch us right now
because we're about to LEAP right into
their world we're on the uh cusp of very
strong AI Quantum computing
uh genetic modification of the whole
thing I mean we're Reinventing our
species we're moving into a new phase of
human existence
we don't want to know that
that was uh the Angels were chiming in
there
anyway so I think I think where an
object of uh
probably we brought the whole
neighborhood in
to check us out at this particular time
wouldn't surprise me at all
I want to introduce Matt O'Dowd who is
the host of PBS space-time a professor
of physics as well as the launcher or
the filmmaker behind inventing reality
which is in its fundraising stage about
several of the topics that you've heard
on the toe channel that is what is
reality what is physics what is physics
relationship to consciousness
Matt
thank you thank you for coming on again
could it is a pleasure to be here again
I feel like I'm home
yeah yeah the first I think the first
podcast I had in this setup was over
here and you were speaking to me so it's
yeah it's nice to nice to have you back
on I'm not sure if you've ever met Brian
or Richard oh Brian Brian and I go way
back hey Brian it's good to see you
again hi Matt Happy New Year
you too so Richard Dolan is a historian
and focuses on the the UFO phenomenon
but I'm sure I'm I'm not even giving the
proper introduction so please fill in
the gaps Richard and Matt I just give
the introduction Matt's a professor of
physics who has a wonderful
YouTube channel called space PBS space
time
hi Richard good to meet you nice uh same
here Matt
what are we talking about
it's uh we're just hanging out Toronto
Blue Jays we're talking about
talking about baseball
yeah
so so Brian are you able to stay for a
bit longer or you have to get going
yeah yeah I can stay until uh until I
get hit in the head with a nice Ice uh
great great a couple more minutes so
Richard so we're going to start taking
some questions from the audience and
well we should have been doing that the
whole time there are many questions
already but I'm saying that right now so
please because the rest are scrolled far
up I can't find them
one of them that came was what do you
think Richard this one's for you but
anyone else you can feel free to riff
off of Richard what do you think the
relationship is between some of these
ancient myths so religious myths and the
phenomenon
yeah I mean I've been on the show
Ancient Aliens about a million times but
I'm actually not someone who uh
really tries to make a lot of strong
connections between uh our ancient
history and E.T I'm I'm a very strong
student of ancient history and uh and
prehistory it's a big interest of mine
uh and also the origin of uh of myths in
our world
and uh whereas I do think that there's
there's reason to think that we've been
monitored uh by let's call them others
for a long time uh I think I've
characterized it as a fairly low level
thing I think it's totally different
than what we're dealing with now in the
in the 20th and 21st centuries so I um I
don't know if we really have enough
information to to make any of these
connections I think when people talk
about people like Zechariah sitchin I
think that was way way just off base not
a not really a supporter of his work uh
and I and I I'm very hesitant I guess
I'll just say to make strong connections
about that I'm not saying it's
impossible but
um I'm I don't think I'm on board with
most of it
Matt have you have you been asked
publicly about your opinions on the UFO
phenomenon
not publicly
um well not not publicly loudly
um I'm sure there have been some YouTube
comments but
uh are you are you saying that because
you're about to ask me or
preparing me yeah this is uh
so
you know those
um those fighter pilots are
extremely highly trained uh
rational human beings
um and and and they saw some [__] and
and we don't know what it is
and it you know apparently the Air Force
doesn't know what it is so I think I
think
it I think they uh verified
flying objects that have not been
identified so so the question is
what are they uh
my gut instinct is to
hypothesize aliens last
but that is because really because I
wanted to be aliens
but I don't want to fool myself
we're at the exact opposite I don't want
it to be aliens but I think it is
why don't you want it to be aliens uh
I'm not really too crazy about the idea
of aliens being here
um not really in love with the idea but
uh I actually do think that that's what
we're dealing with I think uh
you know when I look at the long history
of the modern UFO phenomenon
um you know everything that we know
about from the so-called Tic Tac UFO
incident of 2004
or the USS Roosevelt 2014 2015 in all of
these cases and then the elites to
Jeremy Corbell in 2019-2020
that's all recent but those types of
events have gone on
they were going on in the 90s and in the
80s and in the 70s and 60s and 50s and
the 40s 1940s we have documents military
Declassified showing these objects or at
least having been tracked at 9 000 miles
per hour
what what the heck is that supposed to
be at high altitude 100 000 feet
altitude
um you know they had the other lights
that were very very good at measuring
speed and distance in Azimuth and so
forth and um
I trust their ability to know what they
were doing so they came up with data
that is not easily comprehensible
unless there was a very very clandestine
science project that no one has known
about here
um that's that's got a global presence
and has had one since before the turn of
the middle of the 20th century
I don't know what else it could be and
in fact when you look at uh you know the
few classified studies that we have
access to or at least moderate access to
um within the US military you find
there's always factions that were
convinced that this was an
extraterrestrial or as they would say
interplanetary phenomenon that was
always a very significant group of
people
um and how deep does it go is a real
question so no I think it's actually
quite
I mean I think about Occam's razor quite
a bit and I think that the ET hypothesis
is probably to me it makes the most
sense it makes more sense than anything
else that I can imagine
that's just me yeah I so
I I admit I haven't done
my due diligence
um
I've watched a few can you speak a bit
louder oh yeah sorry I I haven't done my
due diligence on this particular topic
um
uh there there is however a great uh
video by Joe Scott so I don't know if
you guys know Joe Scott he has a uh
science physics YouTube channel also and
he did a
uh what I thought sounded like a
compelling dissection of the UFO report
um
and
I got the sense that it was plausible
that it was a a light phenomenon
as opposed to being actual physical
matter traveling at that speed
um but like I said I you know you've
clearly uh read and researched far more
than I have so I don't want to pretend
like I know
um but I would I would recommend that
video and be curious which report was he
commenting on
this is a year ago the most recent UAP
task force report exactly I imagine
so a question that I get asked plenty
and I'm curious to know Matt
Brian and also Richard your response to
is how can one
scientifically test this phenomenon
given that it's
unrepeatable
so what would be the best way one way is
to just reject the premise and say no it
is repeatable and then here's some way
but well what would Brian
yeah well I I yeah just uh I did did ask
Avi Loeb this very question multiple
times and I've never gotten a
satisfactory answer so he claims
of course uh Interstellar uh object uh
prepared by extraterrestrial
intelligence uh some star system that we
can't you know reconcile with uh because
of the difficulty in orbital mechanics
and reconstructing it
we just do know that it's velocity is
consistent with origin or coming from an
extrasolar location so I said Avi look
you know if I had access to a
billionaire the way that you have access
to a billionaire instead of
slingshotting you know a bunch of iPhone
cameras to proximus and Tory B I would
uh actually redirect them and and send
all my energy to go after omuamua uh
because he he's convinced that you know
over 90 which for Abby he's actually
going through the math he's not saying
ah 90 chance you know I flipped a dozen
coins and you know no he really has gone
through the math and this scribes a very
high much greater than even odds to this
object's extraterrestrial origin
and um and I said well why don't you
convince
um uh you know Yuri Milner to give you
uh you know 10 million dollars to
immediately go after a muamu while it's
still in The Helio you know pause and
and it's still you know within our solar
systems you know nearest boundaries and
it's not so far out as going to four
light years away as it would be for
project Starship I said oh no no no no
and his uh characteristic uh you know uh
chastising voice he said no with Vera
Rubin we're going to discover Reuben
Observatory which is the largest kind of
it used to be called the LA lsst large
uh synaptic survey telescope in Chile
it's a eight meter class telescope and
we'll be using parts of it data and I'll
be using some of our data from the
Simon's Observatory down in Chile as
well to look for planet nine which is
totally other side project of ours on
the Simon's observatory in addition to
looking for inflationary gravitational
waves anyway he said no we're going to
be basically filthy the sky is going to
be you know blotted out by how many
discoveries of these extrasolar objects
we can make but I said do you still do
you have a plan do you have confidence
this thing is could not be repeatable as
you said Kurt why not take your chance I
mean the number of like supernovas we're
overdue for about four supernovae right
Matt I mean in our galaxy we should have
had about you know a supernova per
Century last major one was in you know
1594 Kepler observed it so fortunately
they don't Stack Up
they don't line up and and all go at
once if they're like
okay so so in other words you know don't
don't you know wait for the next one to
come around because your math predicts
that it should go after the one the bird
in the hand and he's been kind of
dismissive of that I I sort of would
would say no if this is not repeatable
we have to make every effort to actually
confirm this object is is real
um and uh you know so he and I have a
friendly debate about that but yeah it
is true a lot of these things are
one-off events on the other hand if you
look back to like what was Aviation like
in
1922 so 100 years ago 1923 100 years ago
um you couldn't really get on an
airplane and get you know stuck by
Southwest I mean you could you could get
on an airplane if you had a lot of money
and a Barnstormer happened to come by
your neighborhood uh Airfield and just
pick you up and take you up for five
minutes for a wing walk
um and and nowadays of course it's
incredibly common unless you're on
Southwest as I said uh but the the fact
is uh where if we're in this you know
nascence of a technology as perhaps
Richard is is hinting at you know that
it's going to be this explosion you know
I would ask the kind of Nancy Kerrigan
question you know why now what you know
why why us you know why here and it's
not really clear
um
as the uh you know as the technological
you know blueprint of us going forward I
do believe we'll be visiting Mars you
know in the future and it's not so
far-fetched to do that because we are in
that barnstorming phase of space flight
so in 100 years from now on you know
when Kurt's great-grandchildren
rehearsing hosting you know Theory of
Everything You know the the second
generation third generation then they'll
be talking about it but would it be
possible that there's a there's a
there's a you know Mass Evolution and
mass
um sightings and actual encounters and
why would that be happening now as
opposed to 400 years ago or a thousand
years from now and I know I've heard
some of the arguments for it but curious
what Matt would say
Matt so to answer the first question
what do we do for a non-repeatable event
that
is how do we test for it I mean it you
know if the stories about UFOs coming
regularly uh true then it's a repeatable
event you just don't know when and
presumably these things are made of some
kind of matter so we might build uh
various detectors radar-like things and
put them across the planet to detect
objects made of matter flying around and
and indeed we have
that across the globe we have uh objects
built to detect
you know icbms
um traveling between the continents uh
so
that I mean we we have the technology to
detect these things and and so
this is why I think it's
you know in order for us to say we
haven't detected them it
requires some kind of very high level
and very very consistent conspiracy and
a a conspiracy of a consistency that I I
don't think our governments have shown
the competence to be able to sustain you
know across
you know multiple election Cycles
um you know and across multiple Nations
um so then
if these things aren't detectable by our
current technology I mean they clear
they're clearly detectable from their
light because they're seen
uh so they're at least detectable that
way perhaps they they hide from radio so
you know we could scan the sky
um more thoroughly than we are but I
feel like
um I feel like you have to look a little
bit about at the pattern of of when
these things are detected and who by and
you can do a numbers game you know if
these things are detected with this
frequency by Air Force pilots and by
um you know
midwesterners and and whoever sees them
more frequently then it's not hard to
extrapolate to estimate how often you
know the average person would see a UFO
and you can ask whether that happens you
can ask whether
they're
um their sightings are somehow
correlated
in a way that points you to some other
potential uh origin for these sightings
um as for things like um
[Applause]
um
I I not only do I not think was
technology
uh I I think it's impossible for it to
have been Technology based on
the very numbers that RV lope has
crunched uh I I did the calculation I
can't remember what it was but but I
think the I think obvious statement was
that okay so this thing is tumbling it
must be a defunct probe that is that is
now tumbling because it's lost its power
or whatever
um
therefore it's not that and if it's not
guided then you can estimate the
abundance of defunct probes in the
interstellar space in order for one of
them to have fallen into our solar
system and the number you get is
insane in that you would need you know
more uh defunct Interstellar probes than
there are
ordinary rocks floating between the
stars and and so you know I think
a brilliant scientist I I think
um
he may be expressing more confidence in
his belief in this than he actually has
yeah
patiently waiting so please what's your
answer to this question and then also
Tyler nicolat and Sorenson I know that
you're waiting so patiently in the
waiting room I'm Gonna Let You in I'll
be quick then
speaking as the non-scientist here
um I didn't really have a qualified
scientific well your husband of this but
I have more knowledge than all of us put
together on this topic
uh what I what I would say is what we
need is is reliable data capture so uh
the idea that I was expressing earlier
by I wish I could recall this particular
German scientist name but there's just a
number of these types of ideas of of
capturing data and then studying it um
now yeah I remember speaking with
Christopher Mellon about this who wrote
a very good piece about uh less than a
year ago calling out the United States
Air Force for its
absolute uh opaqueness regarding
the data that he he said he knows that
it has relating to this subject and was
referencing a large number of U.S
satellite systems that he said these are
perfectly designed for capturing
anomalous data and he says and I'm
absolutely certain they've done that but
we don't have access to that information
so I think you know it's it's not
repeatable as a phenomenon we've known
this for a long time I mean the problem
with science
correct me guys if I'm wrong here but
you know when you're doing science you
you the scientists are assuming that
you're in charge of the experiment uh
but if there's an intelligence that's
beyond your own uh it might be very
difficult to do that you might be
dealing with intelligence that doesn't
want to play the same game that you want
to play and might make it difficult if
that is the case if we're not at the top
of the the intellectual food chain here
in our analysis of something what is the
likelihood that a scientist is going to
be able to get you know it's one thing
if you're studying a virus in a and a
microscope that that'll behave more or
less the way you expect it to but I
don't know if highly intelligent
presumably extremely Advanced aliens are
going to play by our rules so I don't
know if that causes a problem in terms
of scientific analysis but I do think
data capture and historical analysis are
always going to be important my field is
my study is out of History I know that
very well and and the only thing that I
can say
pretty confidently is that the major
governments and National Security
establishments around this world have
engaged with this phenomenon and have
been utterly befuddled by it or Worse
really concerned all right you just
watched a clip from an eight hour live
stream Behemoth Leviathan podcast from
theories of everything which is a
channel where we explore physics
mathematics and Consciousness what is
the Theory of Everything how do you
merge Quantum field Theory with General
relativities click here or in the
description for the full podcast where
there are several people make
appearances all the way from George
Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary Nolan to
Avi Loeb to John verveighkey to Donald
Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description